hey everyone
welcome to simply learn's youtube
channel in this session
we will learn everything about
performance testing we shall begin with
learning the basics of performance
testing
and what is its relevance after that we
shall see
the types of performance testing then we
shall see the performance testing
process
and performance testing metrics post
that we will learn some performance
testing tools
and after we know all about performance
testing we shall see the basics of
geometer and why is it more sought after
tool
for performance testing finally we will
have a look on hands-on demo to
understand the working of
meter and performance testing is
performed using it
but before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and
click on the bell icon so that you can
never miss an update from simply learn
so without further ado let's get started
with the first topic
that is what is performance testing
so performance testing is one of the
most important phases of any product
launch
as it verifies and validates the overall
product performance
this testing can be done in different
forms depending upon the resource
availability
and the type and volume of the user base
the main agenda behind conducting
performance testing on any product is to
make sure that the product's performance
is as expected
before it gets launched into the market
so performance testing is the process of
testing a software application
under a specific workload performance
testing
is a software testing process used to
test the speed
response time stability reliability
scalability and resource usage of a
software application
under a particular workload the main
purpose of
performance testing is to identify and
eliminate performance bottlenecks in the
software application
performance testing mainly focuses on
three factors of a software program
first one is the speed here it
identifies
whether the response of the application
is fast or not
then comes scalability where the maximum
user load is determined
and the third one is stability where the
stability of the application is checked
under various workloads now we know what
is performance testing
let us understand why if we need
performance testing
the only concern of a software system is
not features and functionality
the response time reliability resource
and scalability are also important
factors
so the goal of performance testing is
not to find bugs but to eliminate
performance glitches
performance testing is performed to help
the stakeholders with information about
the application
concerning the application speed
stability and
scalability furthermore performance
testing reveals
what needs to be improved before the
product goes into the market
if there is no performance testing the
software might suffer from issues such
as
running slow while several users use it
simultaneously
inconsistencies across different
operating systems and
poor usability performance testing
determines if the software
or application meets speed scalability
and stability requirements under
expected workloads
applications sent to market with poor
performance metrics due to
non-consistent or poor performance
testing
are likely to bring a bad reputation and
fail to meet the expected sales goals
now we know the relevance and need for
performance testing
let's look at the types of performance
testing
so there are six types of performance
testing namely
load testing stress testing volume
testing
capacity testing reliability testing and
scalability testing let's have a look at
all the six types of testing
one after the other so the first type is
load testing load testing is a type of
performance testing
where the application is tested for its
performance on normal and peak usage
an application's performance is checked
concerning its response
to the user request and its availability
to respond consistently
with an accepted endurance on different
user loads
here the main consideration is the
maximum load the application can hold
before the application starts behaving
abruptly
then another consideration is regarding
how much data the database can handle
before the system crashes the second
type of performance testing is
stress testing stress testing is a type
in which different ways to break the
system are
found that is how much load a system can
sustain
stress testing has an incremental
approach where the load is increased
gradually
the test started with the load for which
the application has already been tested
then more load is added slowly to stress
the system
the point at which we start seeing
servers not responding to the request is
considered the breaking point
here the major considerations are the
maximum load to a system can sustain
before it breaks down
then how is the system broken down and
how will the system be able to recover
once it has crashed we also see
in how many ways a system can break and
which are the weak nodes
that are to be kept in mind while
handling the unexpected load
moving forward the next type is volume
testing volume testing is the type where
the performance of the system is checked
with respect to the volume of the data
to execute a volume test a huge volume
of data is entered into the database
this test can be incremental or steady
test in the incremental test
the volume of the data is increased
gradually generally
with the application usage the database
size grows
and it is necessary to test the
application against a heavy database
if we consider an example let's say
there is a website of college having
small amounts of data
to store initially but after 5-10 years
the data stored in the database of the
website is much more
and has become huge now comes the fourth
type of performance testing
the capacity testing so capacity testing
is a type of testing
where the application is checked for its
capability to meet the business volumes
capacity testing is generally done for
future prospects
here the main concerns are if the
application would be able to support the
future load
if the environment is capable of
standing the upcoming increased loan
and what are the additional resources
required to make the environment capable
enough
capacity testing helps in determining
how many uses or
transactions of a given web application
is capable of supporting
and will perform well during this
testing resources
such as processor capacity network
bandwidth
memory usage disk capacity etc are
considered and
altered to meet the goal to consider an
excellent example of capacity testing we
can see the case of online banking
moving forward the next type of testing
is the reliability testing
reliability testing is a type in which
the application is verified if the
application would be normal again
after an abnormal state it estimates the
time that the system would take to
return to its normal state to understand
the concept
let's say there is an online trading
site that experiences some failure and
because of which
the users are not able to buy or sell
shares at a certain point of the day
but after a couple of hours they were
able to operate their shares and the
application became normal
this is when it can be said that the
application is reliable and can recover
from its abnormal state
the last type of testing is scalability
testing
scalability testing is a type where the
application is determined if it would be
able to scale up whenever needed
the need for scaling up comes when there
is an increase in user load
now when we have learned the types of
performance testing we must learn the
process of performance testing
so the process of performance testing is
divided into eight parts
that is requirement gathering selection
of tools
performance test plan performance test
development
performance test modeling execution of
test
test result analysis report now
let's have a look at all of these
processes one after the other
the first step in the process is
requirement gathering the requirements
are identified and gathered from the
clients by the performance
team this includes getting information
on the application's architecture
technologies database used intended
users
functionality application usage test
requirement
hardware and software requirements etc
the second step in the process is
selection of tools after the previous
step
poc or proof of concept is done with the
available tools
the proof of concept is a sort of
demonstration of real-time activity
but in a limited sense the list of
available tools depends on the tool's
course the protocol that the application
is using
the technologies used to build the
application the number of users
we were simulating for the test etc now
the third step
the third step is the performance test
plan in reference to the above two steps
test planning and designing are
conducted
the process of test planning involves
information on how the performance test
is going to take place
like the test environment workload
hardware
etc moving forward the fourth step is
performance
test development in this step the use
cases
for the identified functionalities are
created
these use cases are shared with the
client for their approval
once the clients approve the use case
the script development begins
these scripts are validated against
several different users and parallel to
script creation
the performance team sets up the test
environment the performance team also
takes care of metadata through scripts
if the client does not take up
that activity so the next step is
performance test
modeling performance load model is
created for the test execution
this step aims to validate whether the
given performance metrics are achieved
during the test or not then the sixth
step is
execution of tests the scenario is
designed according to the load model
in controller or performance center
initially
the tests are not executed with maximum
users that are in the load model
the test execution is done in
incremental order let's say there are
thousand users
then the scenario will begin testing
from 100 then go to 250
then 350 and so on it will gradually
increase and go
up to 1000 users the next step is the
seventh step in our process
that is the test result analysis the
test results are the most important
deliverable for the performance tester
this is where we can prove the return on
investment and productivity that a
performance testing effort can provide
what makes the result analysis process
more effective is that
we must have a unique and meaningful
name for every test result
which will help us understand the test
purpose in the test summary certain
things must be included like the reason
for failure
how the performance of the application
changes regarding the previous runs
it is also a good practice to make a
result summary after each test run so
that
the analysis results are not compiled
every single time
the results are referred then the final
and the last step in performance testing
process is
the report the test results should be
simplified so that conclusion is clearer
and should not create any derivation
the development team needs more
information on analysis
comparison of results and details of how
the results were obtained
the test report is considered to be good
if it's brief descriptive
and to the point now that we know the
performance testing the next important
topic to discuss is the understanding of
performance testing metrics
the first is processor usage which
refers to the amount of time the
processor spends executing the non-idle
threads
second metric is memory usage memory use
is the amount of physical memory
available to the processor on a computer
system
the third metric is this time which is
the amount of time the disk is busy in
executing read
or write request the fourth metric is
the bandwidth that shows the bits per
second used by a network interface
moving forward the next metric is the
private bytes it is the number of bytes
a process has allocated that can be
shared amongst the other processes
these are used to measure memory leaks
and usage then comes the committed
memory
this is the amount of virtual memory
used then the next metric
we have is the response time it is the
time between when the user enters a
request to time
to the first character of the response
is received
next metric is the throughput it is the
rate at which a computer or a network
receives requests per second moving
forward
the next metric is the hit ratios the
hit ratios are concerned with the number
of sql statements that are handled by
caged data instead of expensive input
output operations
and the last metric in our list is the
top weights
these are monitored to determine what
wait times can be cut down to make the
data retrieval faster
from memory apart from this some metrics
like the rollback segment
garbage collection thread counts heads
per second
cpu interruption per second disk you
length etc
now when we know almost everything that
is needed regarding performance testing
it is very important to know the tools
that make performance testing possible
here are the top 5 performance testing
tools in the market today
the first tool we have is the load
runner or hp load runner
as the name suggests the loadrunner is
great when it comes to handling a large
amount of users for testing
the second tool in our list is web load
web load is one of the best testing
tools for stress and load testing
the next tool in our list is load ui
load ui is a great testing tool to map
the scalability
and speed of the target product the
fourth tool in our list
is new load it is one of the fastest
testing tools with a speed of
around 10 times the traditional testing
tools that are integrated seamlessly
into our
existing software with a wide array of
tests the last tool in our list is the
apache j meter
apache j meter is one of the best and
most used testing tools in the market
right now
it is highly capable of creating a large
number of virtual users
working on web server moving forward we
shall talk about jmeter and understand
why
jmeter is preferred over all the other
performance testing tools in the market
so moving forward let's see what jmeter
is
j meter or apache j meter is an open
source software that is
100 pure java application the
application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance j meter is originally
designed for testing web applications
but has
since expanded to other test functions
to understand the concept of j meter let
us assume that
someday your team leads tell you to
perform performance testing on some
website like
facebook or google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing comes to
your mind do you think it's practically
possible to arrange 100 people with
computers and access to internet and
accessing the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for
10 000 users this is when a need for
software like jmeter arises
so what jmeter does is it actually
simulates
it will simulate the real user's
behavior and perform load tests on
server
group of servers network or object now
let's have a look
at some reasons why gmeter is used for
load testing we have divided these
reasons into six parts
the first one is it's free of cost
second one is performance testing of
applications
next one platform independent the fourth
one is customizable
fifth is recording and playback and
finally sixth is the community support
let's see all of these one after the
other the first reason we have as free
of cost
one of the main deciding factors in any
software is its cost
normally a software can range from high
as
six to seven figures per license here
jmeter is free of cost very intuitive
and has
all the possibilities you need to
automate your work then the second
reason is performance testing of
applications
the application is used to perform
performance testing on different types
of applications like
web applications web services ldap
database and shell scripts
jmeter can conduct load and performance
tests for many different servers
and server types web http and https
database via jdbc ldap and jms
the third reason is platform
independence
jmeter is written and developed using
java to run on any environment
or workstation that accepts java virtual
machine for example windows linux mac
etc the next reason we have is that the
jmeter is customizable
since jmeter is an open source
application it enables developers to
customize
whenever needed jmeter has a
comprehensive and user friendly
graphical user interface
parameters are easy to define and
understand scripting is simpler and
clearer and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive
also one screen shows everything you
need the script
the scenario and the analysis the
samplers are highly customizable when
determining
which request to be sent to the host
however samplers don't enable full
control of test actions
moving forward the following reason is
recording and
playback the application provides record
and playback options enabled
with the drag and drop feature making
the application faster
and easier the next and the last reason
on our list is incredible community
support
jmeter is an open source tool with a
brilliant community that keeps adding
features and supports users
who run into issues and problems this
ensures new users always have someone to
answer their questions
and longtime users can improve their
abilities on gmeter
also having an open source tool ensures
that it keeps getting better
and is always in line with users needs
and requirements
finally let's have a look into the demo
that shows the working of
j meter so the first step is we shall go
to the apache j meter folder
in that folder go inside the bin folder
and select the
j meter jmeter.pat file double click on
this file
this might take a while and then the
jmeter window
will open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side
all the test plan elements are added and
on the right side
all the configurations of that element
are added as we are on the test plan
element
we can see the configurations of the
same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container
where all the elements we will be using
to perform this test
will be stored all the requests
listeners
and everything will be stored here
i have renamed this test plan as
performance testing
now the first step is to add thread
group
right click on the performance testing
go to add
then go to thread or users and
select thread group let's name this as
perform here
the thread group refers to the used or
created users or
needed to run this test it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after
there is an error you can choose it the
way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user's hits
third there is a loop count where you
can choose how many times the test will
run for the number of users
you can also choose the test to run in
finite times
there is also a scheduler here to help
you schedule the start time and the test
end time
let's make the number of threads to b2
and let's make the loop count to be 100
the next step is to add an http request
for that right click on the thread group
go to add option and go to the sampler
option in the menu that appears
select the http request option here on
the screen
there is a server name or ipbox we have
to give the server name or the ip in
that
let's pick up a website and place the
link in the box we shall use the simply
learns website here
go to simply learn's website and copy
the url from here
then come back to the jmeter window and
paste it onto the server name box
keep in mind we don't need to give the
http or https since these are protocols
which will come in the other box and
they will be automatically taken in the
http request case
then in the path dialog box we will
leave the forward slash
there since we have to access the root
page and
let's rename this http request as simple
now
to get results we shall add listeners
listeners are something that
are used to provide the outputs of a
load test there are different types of
listeners present in jmeter
and many may be added using plugins we
will use three different
listeners here to have an idea about the
representation that the jmeter provides
for that right click on the thread group
then go to the add select listener
option and go to the view results entry
option
then again right click on the listener
option and choose graph results
and for the third listener again right
click and select the view results in the
table option
now it's time to run the test for
running the test
there are three simple ways first you
can simply click on the green button
here to run
second is you can go to the run option
and choose the run
the test and the third way you can right
click on the first
jmeter and choose to run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
first we will have to save this jmeter
test and then we shall go on to check
the results of the test
here in the view results tree we can see
the test being run
the same in the case of graph results we
can see the throughput option then
we can also see the time the test has
been executing
since we had put the threads to 2 and
the loop count to 100
so the test will run for a while we can
check the view results in the table we
can see different performance testing
metrics on the screen
you can see the thread name label sample
time per second
bytes sort bytes and the latency and
in the tree option when we click on the
test we can see a lot of information
appearing on the screen
these are again several performance
testing metrics and
in the graph results we can see the
graph coming up on the screen now
which represents the test taking place
with respect to the ip address thread
and loop counts
so what jmeter exactly does is creates a
request and sends it to the server
once it receives the service response it
collects them and visualizes those
details
in a chart or graph after that it
processes the service response and
finally it generates the test results in
several formats such as
text xml json so that the tester can
analyze the data
and this was all for today's session
hope you guys found it informative and
helpful
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here